hi guys I'm Greg I'm John and I'm Lauren
Francesca yep from my my Lauren hey
we're gonna watch a video today from
Lauren's channel called bad girl friend
v3 that's the edited version I haven't
put I haven't decided to post it yeah I
need your honest opinion because okay
honestly I thought the idea was funny
but then I also thought it might be a
little offensive and I know that I just
wanted to get some friends opinions
before I actually title it well I am a
dedicated misogynistic Christian okay
great all right but you're exactly the
demo that I'm the demo you're looking
for and what's right now my demo is I'm
just not gonna win with this is how to
not seduce your boyfriend that's what
it's called how to not seduce your boy I
may change the name
I'll probably get seduced by the yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
okay I can't wait
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
myself so I don't know it's not in
Filipino okay if you're worried about
being too offensive yeah I mean think
the comedy is offensive but its total
satire offended well I just don't know
like I will be played will have will be
upset but okay I laughed a lot now I'm
just sitting here wondering like is that
okay I know cuz I don't know if I have
enough person just decide that on my own
I mean I'm Nam was that acted really
Muslim yeah okay I mean he seems like he
meant what he said at the end at the end
of the day it is a sketch it's scripted
and it's about how you're this girl who
is pretty much an idiot and it's being
established that you're dumb and it's
and he's the guy speaking the voice that
everyone in the comments would be
speaking knowing like this is insulting
this is offensive you're gonna be doing
this so because you have that guy in
there saying all those things then it
makes the sketch okay otherwise if both
of you were like yeah I'm a terrorist
like into that and it would be a little
bit more edgy and more questionable
about whether you should do it but I
think it's fine do you think the
terrorists line whence you far like me
saying like I want you to know I'm yes
I'm glad you went that far otherwise I
would have felt like you were holding
back no not necessarily I mean like
that's what I do suppose happy is a
little too much but people I mean with
this whole like Muslim band stuff
everyone pretty much knows it's
ridiculous the Muslim ban and this is
capitalizing on how ridiculous that [ __ ]
is yeah so it's not I don't I wouldn't
take the the sexy cop role playing yeah
yeah I like that it's edgy and offensive
but it's like done in a way work yeah
you'll get those people who will comment
who will be [ __ ] you I'm scared I feel
like oh I feel like more than anything
this will people will like the venue Ali
you will push buttons but I think you're
pushing the right buttons you're not
doing something right if you're not
pushing those buttons yeah I don't know
with all this PewDiePie drama I've just
been really scared to like do anything
good it'll go away oh wait the PewDiePie
drama have a guy like draw from maker
oh well no there's no one in PewDiePie's
videos to go dude you should have been
making not CJ he's made like a few
hantai semi jokes some pretty bad ones
where he's not really having a voice of
some voice of reason in the videos so
people are not catching on to the satire
but here the satire is very apparent
plus we have this video yeah
well subscribe to the river Lords
channel that was really funny I don't
know your funniest ones you ever done
subscribe it I want my Lauren link in
the description box Jon's research area
and Twitter an instance of media manager
of the real rejects in bloom house take
care
Trump's glorious America huge